spring in Lane Kiffin the former
offensive coordinator with Alabama now
the head coach at Florida Atlantic coach
thanks for joining us let me start with
that decision at halftime who makes that
call and how would that have gone over
with you as the offensive coordinator
nick says I'm bringing into it I'm sure
that was I'm sure that was the assistant
coaches you know bringing that up you
know actually you know if you look at
the Sugar Bowl I said last Tuesday
watching the Sugar Bowl you could kind
of see on the sidelines and players
coaches and knowing people in that
building you know they were pushing for
- in the Sugar Bowl you know when they
were struggling on offense you know - it
had it had this unbelievable month
leading up the Sugar Bowl preparation
you know there were a lot of thoughts
throughout the year that that tool was
the best quarterback you know but and
that building meet a lot of times people
don't bring up their real thoughts on
things but you know Jake Brown was
committed to Alabama and you know the
story goes that Jake home goes to
Georgia when Kirby leaves but actually
we we know at the time we're probably
getting two other the same class
obviously you know from Hawaii so I had
been out there in the spring with him so
we actually were okay with Jake going
that's kind of the unwritten story
because we knew we were getting to it
and thought - was was gonna be just just
an unbelievable player and talent and
his preparation for the game is like no
other but you are big Jalen Hurd's fan
you were tweeting that that you know
leave him in there you can win this game
would you have fought Nick Saban if
Saban says let's bring in tua would you
have fought to keep in hurts in that
position wow I didn't we leave them in
the game I don't know where he got that
no no you got I think at that point you
had to make it you said time to roll let
to number two play he will win it yeah
yeah that was before the UK did you feel
that way and a half time well I didn't
think you got to see what was going on
you know as you're watching the first
half but history has talked about I mean
it was a terrible game I mean there's
there's hardly any first downs and the
defense they're playing great but you
know missing throws people not blocking
people coming off the edge you know as
crazy
John's first knife could have been worse
had jail and knock got them out of
trouble they won't block anybody that
first half and in really I think you
know not to be critical but I think
everybody's code kind of its well
document not a very creative first half
offensively right correct what would you
have done in the Fergana on Alabama side
yeah but it felt like Georgia was saying
we're gonna make you one-dimensional go
ahead throw if you want but we're gonna
take our chances of shutting down the
run what would you have done well I
think first off or there would have been
a different totally different plan but
that is just yeah it is what it is what
watch this film from seven days before
you know what's Oklahoma we have a half
35 yards and 400 or 35 points at 400
yards or something like that you have to
play when you play those those two
defenses you got to play with tempo
unbelievable fast tempo with multiple
formations where you're going really
fast you're giving them problems you
know Ryan pass you know that will go
slow and you know motion everybody and
you know that NFL style I don't work
against you against those guys it never
has
you know never will watch you know when
Alabama has played the Georgia's LSU's
you know it was all the same you will
move the ball you've got a play like
Oklahoma did and look at the last four
times the last four games that in the
season prior to this Oklahoma you know
beat Alabama and scores 35 or 40 or
something
Ohio State puts up 600 yards against
them beat some Clemson should have beat
them almost at 45 to 40 and then Clemson
the next year beats them with another
almost six hundred yards so you know
it's a key of how to do it you know just
neither team did it until the end kind
of you know with two of their there was
a little tempo you know because they
were behind so they had to kind of go
tempo let's say she'd been doing all
game
what was that play it's called Seattle
but are you familiar with that
game-winning score yeah it's four
verticals
you know and so it's three well
information for verticals and the corner
you see the car he it's Tampa - they're
playing on defense the corners should
have rerouted the receiver he didn't
rerun
safety plate too tight on a slot
receiver and that that allows you to
throw it up the field that's a tough
throw and I made a great play on it you
know but the story before that is what
happens I mean you know and no
discrediting either team you know but
players make plays in big-time games
I mean Alabama's dead you know - a sack
there's three guys on 3rd and 8th you
know - it makes all three guys missed
including all-american you know and then
you know look at the look at the play
before you know they get they get sacked
i'ma play before they're gonna if he
doesn't make that throw on see how what
are they gonna do I mean can they can
you make a field goal of that distance
probably not now the game's basically
over there only enforcing forever so
thoughts why it's wide 75% of games
recruiting and that's why coach Saban's
the best is is not because of the coach
well he obviously coached all he's best
recruiter in the country you know look
who look who's making plays at the end
they're handing the true freshman from
Hawaii is handing the ball to the true
fresh Northern California no windows out
of a heaviness Alabama that doesn't
unless you you've established a program
that can nationally recruit which really
Alabama has never been that program in
Adana California Hawaii got got those
guys in till the last few years yet was
incredible as I'm watching this in that
final drive you had freshmen on the
offensive line a freshman running back a
freshman wide receiver and a freshman
quarterback that doesn't happen at
Alabama it feels like you know freshmen
can't make an imprint it takes a little
while to do that but they certainly did
on this team I was surprised at that
yeah they sure did and um you know that
the game being obviously the whatever it
is 14 came in the air you know those
guys had a whole extra month of practice
leading up to it and obviously things
you know we're great players in the
first place two-parter you know and the
more on signing class in the country
what do you think Georgia should have
done in the second half that they didn't
do I think their defensive plan was fine
again you know we always look at you
know outcome as fans you know and not
really look at what happened I mean
they've got them we just said dead to
the rights a guy doesn't
last play but they've got to a sack on
third down you know and then a touched
on the drive three guys they're you know
that should be an easy easy sack there
so you know I think that the other side
you know obviously you know George you
got conservative you know and so the
downside of that is if George is in
conservative and goes interception well
hey they haven't been moving the ball
why are you not being conservative so
that's a little tougher call but you
know obviously they did get very
conserved on offense and the problem
when you do that with Alabama is now the
plan right in their hands you're going
slow and you're running the ball I'm
using the tackles second half Alabama
runs of all or so second half Georgia
runs of all four one point four yards of
carry
you know because you can't you can't get
back into that stale you know old school
whatever you call it you know pro style
offense we're talking to Lane Kiffin
Florida Atlantic head coach what do you
think Jalen hurts his future is at
Alabama no I think that's a great
question you know I you know had this
that the funny thing is if the second
half doesn't flip like this you know and
how about if the ball doesn't change it
you know people that really know what's
going on will tell you that to to is
leaving
you know because to a thought that he
should and the starting quarterback and
had outperformed in practice and in
coach never gave me an opportunity so
how does this second half that happened
changes college football cos because -
it was going to be one of the best
quarterbacks in college football it
means he plays just like Steve Young's
unbelievable talent unbelievable
releasing to get out of trouble as you
saw so but you know what you're saying
though Lane is if he didn't get in this
game you think that - is transferring
from Alabama no doubt he's already he's
played some so he's gonna have to sit so
he's gonna go sit he's gonna have three
or four three or so sit for a year and
half three years to play he's gonna sit
there for another year behind Jalen you
know when he feels like he didn't did an
opportunity to beat him out so now now
the story's gonna flip the other way you
know and and you know the story's gonna
be is Jalen gonna let leave now Jalen
such a great competitor
he may not but most guys would you know
most people would would leave in this
situation and so that would be
interesting to see you know and and the
thing is your
so late you're on january 9th here you
know school start you know you know we
started yesterday so a lot of schools
start their spring semester already so
it'll be a decision has to make pretty
quick and also what you're saying is
that when from turned down Alabama to
follow Kirby's smart to Georgia Alabama
didn't shed a tear because you guys
liked to uh better than from yeah you
know not obviously that was never
released publicly
you know because you talk about recruits
and you know say that afterwards yeah
no I'm not there until you up story yeah
now don't get when we thought Pharma was
great when watched him practice this guy
was unbelievable leader a great baseball
player no great command of the team in
practice you know knew this guy was
gonna be really really special but just
when you just watch to his talent you
know that this was off-the-charts unique
from is a great leader mom is very
talented but Jake problems on a
first-round draft pick you know that's
not you know you don't watch him and say
okay I guess I'm a first-time graphic
you watch the neck has a great college
quarterback you know we if he has right
surrounding surrounding cast also which
he does have you know phenomenal cast
around them you know to has got a higher
ceiling I'll leave you with this do you
think Nick Saban ends his coaching
career to Alabama no no no what's he
gonna do no now I'm not saying retire
but do you think this no no he's a lifer
I get that but do you think that he when
he stops coaching he will be stopping
coaching in Alabama I would say probably
95% you know the 5% of its a you know
his ego you know it's the right it's the
right NFL job you know the Giants or
something like that if it was the right
after our job maybe his ego you know
drives him to prove that he could do it
on that level because you know already
questions whether he came whether he can
you know so that would be it but I'd
they like living there so much and you
know they've got it going so much that
it becomes easy you know at this point
because that and how hard is it for him
to walk into the living room cricket you
know every kid since he's gotten there
every kid
think they said step every kid that has
signed with Alabama since the day that
he got there has won a national
championship I don't know if he knows
that step you know to me that's the
first thing he says when he walked in a
little walks in the living room
I can guarantee you're on a national
championship all I got news where all
those rings when you walk into that
living room yeah you're right about that
he's deserved and again it's he's a
phenomenal coach you know was the game
managed great last night not really you
know wasted time out and stuff but at
the end of the day he has better players
every time you knew that every time you
walked onto the field you know you knew
you had better players than the other
team and that's that's all because of
his recruiting
Leyna always good to talk to you enjoy
the offseason and we'll talk to you next
season all right you two let's Lane
Kiffin Florida Atlantic head coach
former offensive coordinator there had
to get in a couple shots there that
played calling wasn't that good
Continental Tire coaches corner from
Sunday rain to snow and everything in
between Continental Tire is engineered
to tire for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more
information and the location of a dealer
near you visit Continental Tire calm
cutting on a tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]